so Rod Stewart good to hear from you
this afternoon thank you so much for
calling in what made you pick up the
phone uh Sarah hi I've been watching the
program all day and uh yesterday I went
for my yearly scan which is private
obviously and I was 20 minutes late and
I phoned in I said I'm terribly sorry
RPD I did it was a half an hour late I
phoned you and I got in there and they
said I said I'm so sorry I'm so late I
said oh we're not busy at school we've
only got a couple of customers today I
won't tell you where it was but my point
being this is ridiculous you know and I
I would like to pay 10 by 10 or 20 scans
I don't know how we're going to work
this out and hopefully some other people
will follow because it seems ridiculous
at this particular scanning Clinic was
empty and there are people dying because
they cannot get scans now listen to me I
don't need the publicity
um I you know I just want to do some
good things and this I think is a good
thing because if other people follow me
I'd I'd love it so that's such a
generous thing to do thank you for
calling us and somehow we'll work it out
because that's such a great offer and
I'm sure you know callers like Ezra that
we spoke to earlier on on the program
here he's been through prostate cancer I
mean that kind of generosity is
literally a lifeline and you've been
through too bad I've been like within
the NHS uh well obviously it wasn't
within the NHS I went privately because
you know I've got a few Shillings as you
know Sarah but um it was tremendous but
I know damn well this this NHS has to be
rebuilt it's been around since 1947 it's
got to be rebuilt with billions of
billions of dollars that's the only way
we're going to go around it okay
until Eddie I'll play for his scan and
10 or 20 others however however much it
takes no no and and so Rod you know I
know you watched Sky News a lot and
you'll be well aware of all the strike
action uh that's taking place amongst
NHS staff it's continuing into February
and March there's no end in sight and
what are your thoughts on what the
government should be doing about NHS
workers who want decent pay and they
want conditions they want to save the
NHS in their words absolutely they're
not asking for a great deal
um I personally have been a Tory for a
long time but I think this government
should stand down now and give the labor
party a go at it because this is
heartbreaking for the nurses it really
is heartbreaking in all my years of
living in this country I've never seen
it so bad and anything I could do to
help go on the nurses I'm on your side
and I'm sure you have family members who
have used the NHS as well like you said
there are
um people like yourself lucky enough to
be able to afford private care and
that's something that more and more
people are exploring whether they're
wealthy middle income earners or just
scraping the money together to help
themselves or family members how is it
how important is it that we have a
Health Service a National Health Service
that is free at the point of entry from
the Cradle to the Grave if you like how
important is it that the NHS stays as it
is and isn't privatized or is that
somewhere some way of saving it
privatizing it in part well maybe
they're somewhere down the middle you
know if we're going to privatize it it
could become terribly expensive
um as for my family my immediate family
and all my kids I'm lucky enough to send
them to to a private service but uh I
don't know this is this is a bad time
for us in Great Britain it really is
change the bloody government
okay
you're making your political political
points very clear here on Sky News do
you have to point out obviously that
people do have other views and you know
we have had callers on here saying give
Rishi soon a chance they promise to sort
out
um the National Health Service and other
issues facing the company uh country but
of course you know um the government
have been around for over a decade now
which is the Counterpoint to this
argument just just private sector thing
is interesting because the NHS is buying
more has more contracts with the private
sector now than it did before covid it's
making a huge use of the private sector
but of course the private sector charge
is a premium to to private patients and
they don't get paid as much for doing
work for the NHS as they do for their
private clients and what we see so they
don't there's no great incentive for
them to do it and what we see with
private services and I've experienced
this as well with my own family is
whenever there's they can sort of cream
off the patients who they want to see so
if there is any risk for example in
mental health services or if there is
sort of difficult cases when things go
really badly wrong actually people are
fed back into the NHS it is interesting
they've got a I think I'm right in
saying they've got about 800 operating
theaters most of them don't have itus so
if anything goes wrong during an
operation they have to ring 999. right
bear with me we do have to say goodbye
sir Rod Stewart thank you so much for
calling in just a final question if I
may and you've been listening to the the
program today members of the public
calling in having their say this
afternoon is there a particular story
that's resonated with you
uh every one of them I must admit I have
the television on the back you know in
the background while I'm working on my
model right
but uh it it it's it's just terribly sad
I'm so proud to be British and I can't
stand it being in this way so you're
doing a great job you guys on there keep
up a good work and I'm a big fan of
Sarah oh well funny enough I'm a big fan
of yours
take care of you guys my mum's favorite
Maggie May okay
we did wonder how we were going to end
the program on a positive note today
you're delivered um
and the offer of 10 to 20 cancer scans
for people will get in touch off air to
Rod Stewart and we'll sort that out
thank you so much
as you say thank you
you never know who's watching you never
know who's watching